well I think that you are somebody who
has an immeasurable amount of
influence and more overpower when it
comes to this rap [__] like I had this
conversation uh are you familiar with an
artist named L Russell L Russell he's
from uh Oakland he does concerts in his
backyard independent kid who okay um but
we were talking about it yesterday and I
was like you know there's a few artists
in this
game Who if they went independent could
break the music industry and really kind
of expose it right and you were one of
those names I think it's you I think
it's Drake I think it's the
weekend who really have the power to
kind of like shift the industry you've
already done it in such a way especially
when it comes to
YouTube but you know you're one of
you're one of them bro you're him bro
like you know I think you you you uh you
definitely have a future outside of of
ending up back in jail hey I real life
hate this
[__] you real life hate this [__] take a
toll on me yeah my my
wife you kids just the music industry
being famous just I wouldn't blame on
the
industry it's all it's all about how you
go about it and I'm not that
strong that's important to uh be
self-aware about man I cry a lot
literally I'm at a point I know it's
okay like my wife I don't know bro how
how much therapy have you uh tried to go
to I know we talked earlier you going to
rehab but therapy is an important um
tool in anyone's box not just yours but
anybody's box you know to kind of deal
with some I mean not everyone's as
strong as we try to portray ourselves to
be I uh I tried it when I was 18 it was
court order and I I finished
it yeah I think the court order shit's
different though you know
like I think you could have you remember
listen we you're Soprano's guy remember
Tony had a
therapist yeah you remember that I
thought thought that sh was going to get
him killed before before I actually
finish the show for sure but Tony went
to therapy man and it helped him deal
with so much cuz you know I always say
this like for whatever reason men in
this world we're not allowed
to society doesn't they frown upon us
being hurt they frown upon us having
feelings we're supposed to hold it
together we're supposed to hold down the
kids we're supposed to hold down our
wives we're supposed to pay the bills
and I feel like
if you're the head of your household if
you're the head of your crew if you're
the leader who do you talk to if you're
going through some [__] you know what
I'm
saying do you have that person or do you
just internalize it put it out through
the
music I don't even love music to that
point no more while I run to the
microphone and know I don't got that
person to talk
to I think everybody should find that
person I think you should you should try
to go back to therapy
man because I'm I have it um on this
Saturday oh you do
okay you got to be able to talk to
somebody who doesn't already have kind
of like their mind made up about you or
who can't benefit off you you know what
I'm saying so you can kind of get like a
you can kind of bear your soul to
somebody so
Mom
ma hey I can smoke a cigarette in here
what you say I can smoke a cigarette
right
here I don't give a [__] about this
out I'm trying to move in the middle of
the water kid middle of the water mhm
Island
no like you want to be on a
boat yeah nice and the only way you come
to me if the helicopter FL that [__]
and grab you and come back I like that
like lit I want to live on the
water I really like this [__] like I
man this [__] ain't even my playground
right
like I have my own guess [__] like
that other than that like yeah I don't
travel this house